كما دمر الطائرات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
منزلين في خان يونس وبيت لاهيا بقطاع غزه
بعد قصفهما بعدد من الصواريخ فجر اليوم
الخميس وقال شهود عيان ان الغارات
الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت المنزلين ادت
لتدميرهما بشكل كامل من دون ان يبلغ عن
وقوع اصابات كما قصفت الطائرات
الاسرائيليه منشاه تجاريه في حي الزيتون
جنوب شرقي مدينه غزه
للوقوف على المشهد الميداني ينضم الينا من
قطاع غزه مراسل الجزيره وائل الدحدوح من
تل ابيب ايضا تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري اهلا بكما وابدا معك وائل
الدحدوح ونحن نتابع معك تداعيات القصف
الاسرائيلي فجر اليوم والاغتيال الاخير
لرابع قيادي في سرايا القدس
حتى الان لا يوجد تداعيات بالمعنى الحرفي
للكلمه او على الاقل قياسا بما شهدناه من
تداعيات لاغتيال القاده الثلاثه ولذلك
اعلنت قوات الاحتلال وجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عن سقوط عدد من قذائف الهاون
في مناطق متاخمه للحدود مع قطاع غزه خصوصا
قباله المنطقه الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه
بالقرب من موقع كوسوفييم وعلى امتداد هذا
الشريط الحدودي قبل قليل ايضا اعلن عن
اطلاق صافرات الانذار في مناطق مماثله
ولكن جميع هذه الصافات تقع في قلب منطقه
غلاف قطاع غزه بمعنى انها تستهدف ربما
بقذائف هاون او قذائف صاروخيه قريبه قريبه
المدى وبالتالي تستهدف هذه المناطق وتطلق
صافرات الانذار
من خلالها ولكن بالتاكيد ما يترقبه الجميع
هو ليس هذا النوع من القذائف ولكن
بالتاكيد هذا النوع لا يعتبر او لا يندرج
في سياق التداعيات التي قالت عنها الجهاد
الاسلامي وسرايا القدس بانها سوف ترد على
هذا الاغتيال الرابع كما ردت على
اغتيال القاده الثلاثه التقديرات في
اسرائيل هي الاخرى تشير بان الجهاد
الاسلامي يمكن ان يطلق صواريخ باتجاه
مناطق متعدده باتجاه اهداف اسرائيليه
تكون ابعد في العمق من من منطقه غلاف قطاع
غزه ولكن بشكل عام في القطاع هنا
ما تزال الطائرات المسيره الاستطلاعيه
تحلق بكثافه في اجواء محافظات القطاع
والتوتر هو سيد الموقف والترقب ايضا هو
سيد الموقف اخر الغارات بالتاكيد كانت تلك
التي استهدفت هذا القيادي في سرايا القدس
وقائد الوحده الصاروخيه من خلال استهداف
هذه الشقه السكنيه في بنايه سكنيه في
مدينه سكنيه هي مدينه حمد في خان يونس
جنوبي قطاع غزه وربما نفس السيناريو لجات
اليه الطائرات الاسرائيليه ومن خلفها
بالتاكيد غرفه غرف العمليات في جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عندما استهدفت القاده
الثلاثه لتفجر هذه الموجه من تصعيد ذات
السيناريو وربما ذات السلاح ونفس التكتيك
وكل هذه
الامور المشابهه استهدفت شقه سكنيه كان
يتواجد بداخلها هو ومعه اثنان اخران
استشهداء واصيبا اصيب اصابات مباشره وحسب
المصادر الطبيه وشهود العيان تحدثوا عن ان
الشهداء وصلوا عباره عن اشلاء لدرجه ان
في الساعات الاولى او اللحظات الاولى
يصعب التعرف على هويه الشهداء وعددهم
وبالتالي مكثت استغرق الطواقم الطبيه فتره
حتى تعرفت على العدد النهائي للشهداء بسبب
الاصابات المباشره والاحتراق والتناصر
الاشلاء وايضا الحطام الذي
خلفته هذه الغاره في هذه الشقه السكنيه
خصوصا وانها اتت في ساعات متاخره من الليل
او ساعات الفجر هذا اليوم
وبالتالي هذه الغاره كما قلنا هي تكرار
لسيناريو اتبعته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ويعني السؤال هنا هل ستقدم الجهاد
الاسلامي فعلا على اطلاق دفعات صاروخيه من
قبيل تلك الدفعات التي شاهدناها ربما
وطالت اهدافا بعمق يصل الى مدينه تل ابيب
او بئر السبع او اقل او اكثر هذا هو
السؤال الذي يمكن ان يعني تحمله او تحمل
اجابات عليه الساعات القادمه خصوصا مع
الحراك او استمرار الحراك فيما يتعلق
بالتهدئه وتفاهمات وقف اطلاق النار ومع
الحديث الذي
يعني ربما افصحت عنه الجهاد الاسلامي بان
عضو المكتب السياسي
للحركه الدكتور محمد الهندي سوف يصل الى
العاصمه المصريه اليوم وفيما يبدو بان هذه
تحركات ربما تعتبر شبه نهائيه للتوصل لوقف
اطلاق النار بين الجانبين وعدم الانجرار
خلف اتساع او توسعه جديده
لهذه الموجه من التصعيد استهداف المنازل
وهذه الشقه السكنيه تتويجا لها بالتاكيد
كان توسعه وكان ما يشبه الضغوط التي تمارس
من قبل الجانبين سواء بهذا الاستهداف او
بالرشقات الصاروخيه التي شاهدناها يوم امس